hello everyone both you did Polgara
non-ag up in - really were considered to
be the strongest women players of their
generation and this is the only game -
two of them played together and well at
the time this game was played the others
poker was around 14 years old and well
she was already an amazing player I'm
already at 16 she was giving the world
champion Garry Kasparov a hard time but
that's to be expected as a Bobby Fischer
livid with her and for her family for a
while but well nah nah Kaplan - really
is actually the first women chess
grandmaster ever and she's also the
first woman to achieve the title of
Grand Master and well she held the world
champion title for 17 years before
losing it to my achiever de Nitza
so let's see this game it's a pretty
aggressive game by nona gaprindashvili
and well the the the ending of the game
is simply magnificent so let's see this
game it was played in 1999 we have efore
by unit and E 5 banana Knight to f3
Knight to f6 so the petrol defense
DeForest played the Steinitz attack I
also sometimes play this is why it's
very enjoyable
we have Knight captures on e4 Bishop to
d3
now d5 and Knight captures an e5
grabbing the pawn back Knight to d7
we have knife capture 77 Bishop captures
and e7 and Pulgar castles here and here
we have Queen to h4 already going for
the attack c4 is played and we have a
queenside castle and now c5 preparing
ideas like b4 b5 and while not allowing
this dark square Bishop to be developed
to d6 but so well this allows for a
different kind of approach we have a g5
by nona gaprindashvili nice the c3 is
played Bishop to g7 going for that d4
pawn and now nice to e2 and okay here
maybe maybe developing a piece with
Bishop to e3 and defending the deep the
deep on wood
like this would have been better but she
played the night Stewie to probably to
bring the night back over to the Kings
side to help out with the defense rook
HD 8 and we have Queen to e1 and now
Knight back to f6 so this night is now
pindani to Queen to d2 on pinning and
now Knight back to e4 at attacking the
Queen and well here probably Queen to e1
is a possibility going for repetition of
moves but the 14-year old unit wants to
go go for the win and she plays Queen to
a5 now going for that a 7 pawn king to
be 8 is played and we have f3 and well
this is the problem of this knight on e4
in the Petrov defense it's not that easy
to get rid of it you can give it you can
always capture it with Bishop captures
on e4 but this is giving up the bishop
pair and if you don't want to give up
the bishop pair you don't have to weaken
your King side gonna move like f3 so
Knight to f3 is played and Knight to f6
sorry
we have g3 now weakening the Kings side
even more Queen to h5 and we have a four
Knights the g4 is played threatening
Queen captures on h2 and well there
really isn't much what what can do here
capturing the knight is definitely the
best move we have captures on g4 and
Bishop captures on g4 and now gap in the
shield is attacking this night and e2
three times the bishop the Queen and the
rook are attacking it so you can't
defend the night you you do have to play
something so what do you do here if you
want to keep the piece that's gonna be a
bit problematic for example you could
play something like Knight to c3 but
this this isn't that this isn't a very
good move as you get Bishop captures and
v4 would check and well what do you do
here you can't block this check with
with the bishop you can't block it with
the rook and you can't really play much
else if you go for example King h1 well
this is pretty much over budget left
recheck only movies rook captures and
after that Queen captures an f3
so this isn't really a possibility after
Bishop to g4 you do have to give some
material back so she you did played
knife to f4 but maybe Bishop captures in
g5 was a better idea
for example if Bishop captures on g5 now
you're attacking this rook on b8 and
well if rook captures then you captured
a row can be a this could have been
played maybe but okay we have Knight to
f4 now Bishop captures on d4 with check
so not yet reacting to this Knight f4
move King to g2 and now capturing the
Knight G captures on f4 we have Bishop
captures on f4 and now Bishop to e5 as
the c7 pawn was under threat c6 is
played and we have Bishop back to c8
although although b6 could have been
played here it's it's not a problem
really for example if Queen to a6 only
then Bishop to c8 and after Queen b5
white will have to spend a lot of time
with moves like a 5 but ok after c6
Bishop to see it is played and this is
also also possible we have Queen to b4
now Bishop to d6 is played wouldn't
attack on the Queen Queen to b3 and our
Bishop captures on f4 we have rook
captures an f4 and our rook to e3
now pinning this Bishop here we have
Queen to c2 on pinning and now Queen to
h3 with check King goes to h1 and now of
course as this pawn is pinned here rook
captures on g3 with well if this Queen
ever moves from C to queen g2 is
checkmate so we have C capture some b7
we have bishop capture some b7 and here
you the plays rook to f7 and well this
is of course the threat the threat is
simple Queen captures on c7 followed by
Queen captures zombie it with checkmate
so capturing this bishop is impossible
to win a piece and well yeah you can't
really make instant progress with a move
like d4 check as better play for covers
it up
so what do you play here after rook to
f7 we have worked the c8 a defensive
move but what will be in very big
trouble soon unit plays Bishop to b5 and
well here comes d4 and well this is the
idea here
unit plays Bishop to c6 now defending
this check and also if Bishop captures
Queen captures this will be okay for
white but here no no not that really
ends the game with one beautiful move
and I will let you find the move for
ourselves if you want you can pause the
video I will give it a couple of seconds
as it's quite an automatic move so okay
I do believe that was enough time for
those of you who found the move
congratulations you're quite quite the
chess players and for those of if you
just want to see the move the move is
rook to c3 and after this move you
toggle resigned the game as well you
can't really do anything here I mean
your queen is attacked also this is a
double attack on your Queen and also on
the bishop here on c6 and well if you
capture the bishop for example you lose
the Queen followed by checkmate and if
you captured the rook well then now this
Bishop is not defended Bishop captures
here with a check and well this is just
completely completely winning for black
with the best defense for example rook
g1 you get robbed the g8 with Czech rock
asta block as there isn't really
anything else to do you can go maybe you
can go King to f2 but then you lose the
Queen rock to G do check but if you even
if you block captures you do have to
block it somehow and what this will and
instantly but after this beautiful wrote
the c3 you didn't continue this and she
resigned the game so yeah a beautiful
game by the by nona gaprindashvili and
also a fun fact for the end of this
video
in 1975 Nora
grappling that really had a perfume
named after her so that's it I do hope
you enjoyed this game I would like to
thank Tom Astro me AK Karl Sybil and
Brian Fripp for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and oh yeah and I just
wanted to say called simple the game you
suggested I already did a review on that
game I will send you the link so I am
think all for watching and I will see
you soon